thank you so much excuse me good evening
and thank you very much and thank you
for coming out I didn't expect this many
people frankly on such a beautiful night
and I know what a wonderful gift that is
to give to anybody an hour or hour and a
half here of your time and I'm very
grateful for it and I'll try to make the
most of it I am going to talk about
Lincoln first I heard
Susan's description of my book I must
tell you it was so flowery and so
positive that I had to remind myself I
actually wrote it it's a and it's nice
to hear that about the book because it
was a very important effort for me I had
done a book on Lincoln some years ago
with Harold Holzer
who was a true Lincoln scholar and a
fellow I had worked with for years and
has been a good friend of mine for 20 or
30 years now and the book was a kind of
collection of Lincoln essays on the
subject of democracy that we put
together for two teachers from
solidarity in Poland who came to the
governor's office in Albany and asked me
to come to Poland to lecture to them on
democracy because the Soviets had
finally been driven from Poland and they
had restored or were restoring the
democratic way of life and they said
that they needed some help and being
reminded of what democracy really meant
and I said well I'm not the person for
you let me get a book by not Jefferson
whom everybody thinks of automatically
as the Democrat but Lincoln who was
called a Republican and I'll have it
translated into polish and we'll raise
money and get you a few thousand copies
which eventually we did and send him
over and he's all oh that was wonderful
and I went home and looked in the
collected works of Lincoln by Basler a
copy of which had been given to me as
it's a series of nine by my sister in
1955 as a gift I looked in the index and
under the word democracy nothing
appeared then I was shocked and
eventually recalled
the other Lincoln scholars from around
the United States and I said to them
this is outrageous you know so what we
did was break up Lincoln's life into
seven periods and select one historian
like McPherson over it or any of these
great Lincoln people to that period I
said culled from Lincoln speeches and
writings the best things you have on
democracy will do it in seven sections
have his whole life we put together a
collection of won some prizes and ever
after that the publishers asked me to do
another book on Lincoln I said well I'm
not an historian I'm not going to do
Lincoln's love life Lincoln's feed
Lincoln speeches like I said they're
already doing that he's by far the most
popular president in American history by
far no one's even close everybody uses
him every Democrat every Republican says
he's with Lincoln as it not unless it's
relevant and not unless I can contribute
something that I feel comfortable with
will I do another Lincoln book and
nothing happened until 9/11 and then
nothing happened until the first
memorial of 9/11 and just before the
first memorial of 9/11 a reporter called
me and said we're about to have the
memorial of 9/11 and the governor will
speak and Mayor Bloomberg will speak and
former Mayor Rudy Giuliani will speak
and if you were still the governor and
you had to speak what would you say and
I said oh boy what a daunting prospect
that is I'm glad in a way I'm not the
governor because it's so difficult this
perhaps the most impactful episode in
our lifetime and maybe one of the most
impactful in modern history of the
United States at least what will they
say and if you remember the memorial
came and then it was over and none of
them spoke they recited the names of the
deceased and then read from Lincoln
and I said whoa what does this say about
Lincoln it says something I've always
believed and that Lincoln is more than
just a revered relic Lincoln is relevant
the reason for all that popularity goes
far beyond the fact that he was raised
from a log cabin to the presidency of
the United States he was educated only
for a year formally but wrote like a
poet and spoke like demosthenes it was
more than he kept the Union together in
the Civil War over the odds that he rose
up from terrible unpopularity to be one
of the most popular presidents in
American history that he began the
process of ending slavery in the United
States of America there was something
more than that well as moded him his
martyrdom had a lot to do with it as it
did with John Kennedy in all candor we
have a special place in our heart for
people who are striving and who were
noble appearing and noble acting for the
most part and who then give up their
life for us as martyrs and and that had
something to do with his popularity but
for me it was more than that from the
very beginning from the first time I
read Lincoln I was impressed by his
intelligence I was impressed by yes of
course his magnificent eloquence but it
was much more than that as I grew older
and continued to read him and became a
lawyer myself I was I was just dazzled
by his mind this is a an extremely
intelligent human being a broadly deeply
visionary philosophical human being and
of course a magnificently eloquent one
and so I said if he's relevant and if
he's all these things why don't we use
him more than just at a memorial why
don't we ask him about pre-emptive war
why don't we ask him about taxation
those are both subjects he knew very
well pre-emptive war he addressed
specifically when his partner Herndon
said how do you feel about pre-emptive
war and he answered and the answer is as
relevant today and as pointed as
startlingly relevant as a matter of fact
taxation he invented the income tax
progressive it was unconstitutional when
he did it but he did a number of
unconstitutional things when he really
needed to how about the people will say
when you say let's listen to him on
religion let's listen to him on the role
of government let's listen to him on
race of course he talked about slavery
but what about multilateralism yes he's
good on multilateralism too and people
say no hold it hold it a second you know
how dare you tear him out of context
1865 this is 2004 this is internet
globalization true multilateralism the
shrinking of the globe look at all
that's happened between then and now how
dare you tell us what Lincoln would say
today and suggest is relevant oh really
you use them at the memorial you read
the founding fathers every day in the
courts of this nation to tell you how to
read the Constitution and how to apply
it today have you stopped reading the
Old Testament or Plato or Aristotle or
all those ages of wise people and wise
things that they uttered of course you
make adjustments of course you have to
take into consideration the difference
in time and place of course but the
essential wisdom doesn't change so I
brushed off that silly
I think suggestion well then why don't
more scholars do that the real scholars
you say you're yourself not a scholar
well I've read Lincoln since 1955 as I
say and I are familiar generally with
Lincoln but I haven't studied him the
way the historians do well why won't
they apply him the way you have or maybe
they will when they read my
maybe they'll say you're wrong fine it's
very much like how I feel about
Fahrenheit 9/11 yeah well what do you
think of war what do you think of this
I'll tell you what I think of the whole
thing it's a documentary it's a dice
pictures it's real pictures and he draws
conclusions from it and what I would
love to see more than anything else is
not that you say well every part of it
is right every implication is correct
every insinuation well-founded no no
what I want you to say is it's evidence
thank God instead of 28 second
commercials and so what you should do is
dispute it with evidence if you think
it's wrong if you think Bandai did not
sit down
two days after 9/11 with the president
for three hours in the White House
inexplicably
talking about something that has never
been reported if you can say that's not
so say so but let's argue the facts and
the evidence and all of that wouldn't it
make for a much better much better
campaign than we're going to have with
200 million dollars worth of twenty
eight second commercials huh what can
you say in 28 seconds about abortion
what can you say in 28 seconds about
what you do about terrorism after you
mount the largest military campaign in
your history what can you say in 28
seconds about pre-emptive war and what
it really means and why it's good or why
it's bad very little but you can say it
in a documentary and you can say it in
arguments that call for proof and
evidence and so too with Lincoln I think
you know if you listen to Lincoln you
read this little book and it's a little
book like Lincoln's little book Weems he
loved the Weems book he called it my
little book it was a little book that
had an awful lot of ideas in it in
history and it was rich with advice and
so I I hope you'll get a chance to read
this book the the name of the book is
why Lincoln matters today more than ever
and there's a wonderful wonderful
picture of it and you can see how small
it is it will take you long
and I'd suggest that you read the
introduction first and then you skip all
the way to page 166 and and would come
back later but go to 166 because I'm 166
I have what is more than a conceit it is
Abraham Lincoln imagine him as president
today talking to the Congress in a State
of the Union address but talking about
all of today's problems talking about
what's happened to us with our friends
overseas talking about the war in Iraq
the war in Afghanistan before that the
lack of planning terrorism what needs to
be done with terrorism the domestic
scene what you think of the tax cuts
what you think of the condition of the
people of the United States of America
and all of that is in about 2,600 words
in the State of the Union message and
then come back and you'll find in the
beginning of the book there's a
delightful 15 or 20 pages that Harold
Holzer and I did together about how all
the presidents all the presidents have
used Lincoln and my favorite may rest in
peace because I loved him I really did
President Reagan I got to know him I was
governor while he was president he did
the National Economic Commission in his
last year at my suggestion I was
chairman of the National Governors
Association at that point in charge not
chairman and chairman of the Budget
Committee and if you think all the way
back to then you know we had this
intractable deficit that nobody could
handle and I had a plan for how to
handle it and he adopted it President
Bush undid it a year later the National
Economic Commission and it hurt him Bob
Woodward said if he hadn't undone it he
wouldn't have been forced to give that
tax increase after he had promised not
to and he might have been present for a
second term but anyway I knew him well
and I liked them and told a favorite
joke about having met him I told it here
once by being introduced to President
Reagan and I told the story with
President Reagan sitting next to Matilda
at a gridiron dinner my wife Matilda and
I remember standing up and saying this
isn't the first time I've met the
president
I was introduced to him once or there
was an attempt at introduction and the
introducer said mr. president I want you
to meet and before he could get my name
out of his mouth President Reagan cocked
his head the way to one's will you don't
have to introduce us I know Lee Iacocca
well it hasn't and for one terrible
moment I know I almost said what a kid
from Queens would say to a crack like
that I didn't it got to the tip of my
tongue and prudence bit it and spat it
out I was gonna say no it was the
presence of some people we all look
alike but I never said it and so he was
a wonderful man whatever you say about
his record and there's a lot we could
say about his record is light I did when
I was governor because you know we were
at different ends of the situation he
was cutting the income tax and everybody
else had to raise the regressive taxes
because in order to pay for the income
tax cuts they had to cut the budgets for
the states in the cities and so the city
was in trouble in it etc etcetera does
all of that but it was a great man it
was a great human being and the
character lessons he taught you just by
never showing any anger never showing
any vindictiveness getting shot and
waving out the window at everybody
making Joseph his marvelous person but
with Lincoln he at the 1992 convention
of the Republicans read this series of
epigrams from Lincoln they were
wonderful you know and they sounded like
an absolute response to everything
Clinton was talking about doing as
president until I after was over
somebody looked at these Lincoln
epigrams and said they were written by
some Protestant minister and Lincoln
never had anything to do with them and
the power of Reagan as an individual was
such that everybody ignored the fact
that when they kept quoting them as
Lincoln epigrams and and maybe still do
and so Lincoln Lincoln has always been
gloriously gloriously relevant and can
be much more useful today than he has
been up until now again
there are all sorts of specific
applications global independence etc etc
but the thing that moved moves me most
about him is his vision and the
grandness of his vision and sometimes in
political life and I'm sure you feel the
same way but when you steeped in it and
as I was and still I am to a large
extent though for a long time and you're
studying it all the time and you're even
in a position to do something about it
for 12 years governor 12 years and and
and you're involved in presidential
campaigns and you're debating and you're
fighting and you know you think gee
willikers can't we do better than this I
mean isn't there something more we can
do about this country we're so great was
so powerful even without trying you know
with the world's greatest engine of epic
opportunity ever mama and papa
would never have made it anywhere else
the way they made it here they couldn't
read or write they had no skills they
had no money they had no friends they
came here they raised a family had kids
one of them became a governor the other
two were much better and you know they
look at how wonderful look at all the
money we have nobody has the wealth and
power we have nobody everybody wants to
come here almost very few people want to
leave except occasionally they want to
leave so they don't have to pay taxes
they don't want to leave the residents
they don't leave the protection but
they'll they'll incorporate and Bermudas
so they can beat you on the taxes but
apart from that departure very few
people want to live leave here and so
you say to yourself when you see all
that power and all that strength and all
the good fortune God has given us in all
the resources we have and how everybody
quakes at the idea of taking us on one
on one
you say well then why why do we have the
problems we have why do we have all
these poor people why don't the schools
work why do we have 40 to 43 million
people without health care why is it
that a woman 28 years old 30 years old
with breast cancer without insurance who
works as a secretary but whose boss
doesn't give her a policy which
increasingly is the case for people who
work
it was important enough for Medicaid not
old enough the Medicare has cancer needs
a mastectomy and then she's bankrupted
for life or at least for a long time and
if she happens to be a little bit older
and have a couple of kids you know then
what did she do she's a single spouse
and how does that happen in this country
so you you get aggravated and you say we
we must be capable of something more
than this and so you look at this this
campaign as an opportunity and say okay
we're about to pick another president or
restore the former president but it's
big now we have to deal with war and
then deal with terrorism and deal with
an economy that's a problem and the
sagging middle class okay here are all
the opportunities maybe now maybe now
they'll come forward with something big
some philosophy some big ideas some
coalescing notion maybe they'll have a
plan for us to say this is what we
really are as a people and bring us so
let's see let's see what happens and
what has happened in the campaign so far
so far it's all President Bush why well
because it's terrorism and it's war and
that's what a president does and that's
where we're concentrating and we're
losing we lost more Marines today and
it'll be a thousand that were killed
soon and maybe 12,000 who have come home
mutilated you can't tell because they
don't really give you the numbers and
maybe 20,000 innocent Iraqis that have
been killed but we can't tell that
either because they don't give you those
numbers either but all of this is
happening okay mr. president so what is
your plan what is your big idea what is
your philosophy I'm confused what do we
do well you know so far we're gonna be
the strongest got a powerful military
we're gonna beat Saddam Hussein and and
we got Saddam Hussein and he's going to
get executed and we're still facing
Osama and we got military might and we
won't give up until we've finished and
and we're going to create a democracy in
Iraq
all right then then what then that's the
end of terrorism you're going to kill
the terrorists and does that end them
and the answer is no of course not we
know that ask strong ask anybody in
Israel you can't end it by just killing
the terrorists because
produces other terrorists that's how
difficult it is it's a cancer and a
terrorist is a malignant growth and so
you have to extirpate it but it it's not
enough to pull out the growth because
the cancer is still there and in this
case the extirpating of one produces
others automatically so you've got to do
something about getting to the disease
so we don't want to talk about that
that's mushy liberalism your next thing
you hear is root causes my god oh no
let's not talk about root cause why
should we talk about root causes just
because that's the only intelligent
thing to talk about after you've tried
force and no force alone is not enough
and so so we're not getting it from the
bush people and we haven't gotten it
from the Democrats yet why because he
hasn't had his chance yet Kerry why
because you're not looking at him yet
soon you will soon you'll have to
because before people in this country
will vote they're going to make sure
Kerry comes out and say ok let's see
what you have now they're not gonna say
we looked at Bush and he's not adequate
that won't happen no matter how less
than fully adequate he may be people
know what whatever your judgment people
will say you've got to show me something
better and if you don't he will be
President no matter what the polls say
now and so that so we haven't seen that
big idea that big philosophical vision
that's what Lincoln had and that's what
appeals to me most his words and acts
expressed the two great principles we
live by or should live by as taught by
all the great religions you know I had
an opportunity I never said it myself
but I had an opportunity to you know be
considered for the Supreme Court of the
United States actually it happened twice
but and and I didn't say it but it came
out and was in a book by Stephanopoulos
and then President Clinton talked about
it and every once while people say gee
willikers why today you know you love
the law and you you they say pretty good
at it
why didn't you
go to the Supreme Court and and it's
very hard to explain it's very hard to
explain to Mathilda let alone to
everybody else Edna and I'm not sure I
can really try but maybe maybe this is
useful and and or maybe that experience
is useful in thinking about Lincoln
Lincoln looks at the Constitution and
Lincoln was a lawyer and he loved the
Constitution and he knew that it was
this great document this this first of
our 10 Civic Commandments the
fundamental law of the nation that makes
us free the Bill of Rights thank God for
that the freedom to speak to love to
believe it gives us Liberty that's
magnificent
wonderful and we have to protect it at
all costs but that's basically all it
gives us is freedom wonderful but that's
all it doesn't say anything about loving
one another it doesn't say anything
about equality it doesn't say anything
about fairness it doesn't say anything
about hey listen if all people are dying
because they're sick and they have no
wealth to buy medical attention
you should come together and take care
of them it doesn't say that you didn't
get Medicare and Medicaid until 1965 you
passed the compass the Constitution 1789
the Constitution was missing something
it called for slavery and for unfair
treatment to women and many others in
this society but it Liberty yes
Lincoln cherished the Liberty obviously
and used that part of the Constitution
but he wanted something more he had a
greater vision so he turned and he
looked at the Declaration of
Independence and the Declaration of
Independence is at a higher level of
morality because it's the Declaration of
Independence that says to you look
there's a force up there beyond all of
us and you can call it god of the
creator of the omnipotent whatever and
we want to be careful about that because
we want to not get into trouble with the
religion
but there's a force up there and
intelligence up there larger than any of
us
that gives us basic rights life liberty
the pursuit of happiness and people are
entitled to equal opportunity and equal
dignity and Lincoln looked at that and
says I'm going to take that Declaration
of Independence and I'm going to squeeze
it together with the Constitution and
make one grand new commitment a
constitution that absolutely keeps all
that Liberty that has given you and
never relinquishes it but at the same
time adds the sweetness of the
Declaration of Independence the love the
compassion that's implicit in it he
believed in two ideas and he talked
about it everywhere it's all through his
work all through his action when he
talks about the economy when he talks
about the rest of the world when he
talks about people in China and you know
he only once stepped out of the United
States and that was to see Niagara Falls
in Canada and in New York we don't
consider that another country or a
foreign policy you know that's upstate
New York Canada or at least beyond the
fault but despite that he talked about
it always to principles it's going to be
familiar to a lot of you in this
audience but these are his two
principles number one equality equality
of opportunity not equality of result
nobody ever promised mama and papa don't
worry you're gonna do just as well as
those people who were here three
generations ago but they did promise
mama and papa don't worry you'll get a
shot you know you'll be treated fairly
in terms of having the opportunity to
succeed
he believed he believed look you're
supposed to love one another as
individuals and what are we supposed to
do with that relationship that you know
that sense of well we're all equal and
therefore all equally entitled to
dignity and and as a practical matter
we're all interconnected and
interdependent words you didn't hear
again until vaclav havel and Gorbachev
well what do we do with that is it well
what you do with it is you come together
and you make the society better and you
work to make this country stronger all
of you together the labor with the
owners of the capital capital is
important but you'd be nowhere if it
weren't
for labor that's Lincoln and so treat
those working people right
let them be more efficient we would go
stare paid better etcetera etcetera so
love one another and work together to
improve the societies that sound
familiar
isn't that sadaqa and tikkun olam and
isn't that the beginning of monotheism
and didn't the Christians say exactly
the same thing Lincoln wasn't religious
Lincoln wasn't religious Lincoln was not
religious formally religious Lincoln
said God frequently quoted the Bible
always but when asked are you a Jew a
Muslim a Christian Buddhist Muhammad is
he your God or your your disciple or
your apostle or whatever your leader
religiously he said no none of them said
well why don't you belong to a specific
religion said because they all have
rules and regulations admonitions and
prohibitions that require you to suspend
your intellect and to accept them
without being able to prove it
intellectually well of course that's why
they call it faith if it weren't for
that you call it knowledge it's faith
you've got to believe it because you
choose to believe it at one point it's
it's something not compelled by your
intellect but not rejected by your
intellect either and that's more or less
conforms with your the evidence you see
it it's not rejected by the evidence but
it's not compelled by the oven so I
choose to believe it I choose to believe
there's this great infinite power well
can you describe it now it's infinite
and I'm here I mean you know I got a
little shrunken mentality 98% monkey I
mean what did so those those are the two
Lincoln principals and that's what we're
missing in this world and it has all
kinds of consequences he would say this
for example he would say like what would
you do with the war forget about
pre-emptive war he told Herndon you
can't have a pre-emptive war why because
if you let the president decide when to
go to war without going to the Congress
it's the Congress who has the right to
declare war if you say to the president
if you think
it is going to invade you can invade
Canada first if that's what you do maybe
the president will be wrong and you
didn't have a chance to stop him because
he decided on doing it
maybe he'll be cynical maybe he has
another idea maybe he's gonna start a
phony war we've done that in our history
as you know maybe he's gonna start a
phony war you've gone around the
Constitution you're supposed to go to
the Congress that's why they gave the
Congress the right to declare war so
don't do pre-emptive war so he wouldn't
have started the pre-emptive war in Iraq
how about Afghanistan would he have gone
to war in Afghanistan absolutely why
because he went to war didn't he to keep
the Union together with a fury he went
to war he was one of the tough he was
tougher commander than most of his
generals and he demanded more and he was
a nut on weapons of mass destruction
given the limitations of weapons of mass
destruction at his time and he worked on
new battleships new guns new everything
so he was a fierce fighter but he never
would have started the second war
against Iraq that was a pre-emptive war
and he wouldn't have started a second
war before he finished the war in
Afghanistan because he was against two
wars and he would have realized this he
would have been he's smart enough to
realize that you can't win the war
against terrorism for the reason I've
just given you before the cancer analogy
with just force yes you need force you
yes you must catch the bad guys yes you
must get Osama yes it was good to take
down Saddam Hussein but that's not going
to stop the Terrorism you have to stop
the propaganda of the moderates 'as you
have to do something to relieve whatever
it is that's making them hate us and
that doesn't mean weakness that means
strength and intelligence and he
incidentally the President himself Bush
believes that if you look at the
pre-emptive war statement in his defense
policy of September 2002 which is where
it appears for the first time in that
same document he says what I would have
said as a governor about crime here in
the United State of New York you can't
stop the crime he says you can't stop
the terrorism with just a police force
courts and press
and he says the same thing we can't do
it with just force and so he gives colon
Powell two programs one is the
Partnership Program of the Middle East
to get together with Arab nations and
others that have money and see if you
can't spread some of that money to
relieve some of the poverty that's
creating a provocation etc nice idea and
and and the second program the
millennium program and then he didn't
fund it and so it's there he admits you
need it Lincoln would be funding it
domestically I'll just settle for this
because I want to spend more time with
you than to deliver it all by way of his
speech here are the facts and you decide
what Lincoln would do Lincoln created an
income tax and he made it progressive
and he said I'm making it progressive
because the people with a lot of money
get a lot of money because they're
living here in the United States of
America they worked hard they were lucky
they're brilliant but also they get it
because the country is great and the
army protects them and it produces
workers and it helps give them customers
so it's only fair that they should pay
more than the poor people and the middle
class struggling people everybody should
pay what's reasonable for them but the
wealthy people should pay more nothing
wrong with that I don't think and so
that's what he believed in and he did it
and he said it and he said it over and
over and he said it as a legislator in
Illinois and he said it as a congressman
the one term he had and he did it as
president they declared it
unconstitutional later and then he had
the 16th amendment to make it
constitutional but that's his position
today you have 280 290 million Americans
140 million workers 2% of the population
makes $200,000 or more two percent
that's 2 million of the taxpayers 2
million of about 110 million taxpayers
make $200,000 or more just two minutes
there were tax cuts in the first place
the tax cuts occurred because we had a
big depth
surplus which Clinton had left us and
that was the reason for the tax cut so
we're going to give the money back
especially to the rich people who gave
it to us because we don't need it and so
there was a big tax cut 40% of which
went to the richest people in the
country and then we lost the surplus the
wars came more expenses for Iraq the
economy went down everything went bad
and we gave more tax cuts and now if you
look over the next seven eight nine ten
years you'll be giving some numbers
project as much as a trillion dollars
even if there's only five hundred
billion dollars to the top two percent
what what but then you say this morning
that the deficits larger than it's ever
been yes and the debt is large it has
ever been yes and Social Security and
Medicare and in 20 years
going to be in trouble yes and and the
city of New York had to raise taxes
because it got shorted yes and you need
more money for you Iraq yes and the high
schools the colleges the tuition is
going up when you need skilled workers
more than ever and only one out of every
four American workers is high skilled
because they can't get a college
education and you're losing jobs
overseas didn't you say that yes and
you're going to give a trillion dollars
away in ten years to the richest people
in the country how dare you how dare you
that's what that's what Lincoln would
say only he would say he would say it he
would say it in poetry religion is good
to religion maybe we ought to talk about
the one thing he would not do is build a
policy on a rationale that's purely
religious because it wouldn't make sense
right I mean if you were a Jewish
president or a Catholic president or a
Buddhist president or Confucian or
whatever you wouldn't say well I have
this principle that the other people
don't share the other religions and the
our religious population they don't
share it it's mine
where did you get it well I got it from
my church and you know but where did
they get it who knows there I'm in the
church that you get it the if you don't
believe it you get out of the church I'm
in the church I want to stay so I
believe it well that's the way it works
well you wouldn't build a policy on that
no in order to go to this population
which they're not religious and you're
Jews and you're this and you're that and
in order to do that you have to give an
idea like I'm against murder that's what
my religion says and that were good we
all agree so you have to have a secular
basis to it what is the principle that
allows President Bush to say that Nancy
Reagan is wrong and that you can't tell
take embryonic stem cells the principle
is life begins at conception life begins
at conception is what we Catholics are
taught by the church it's a religious
predicate and a very big one for
Catholics
it's the predicate of the abortion
position life begins at conception
therefore no woman can have an abortion
even to save her own life well is that a
scientific principle dr. John Marburger
who's the bioethicists who works for
President Bush was asked that question
it's in the new york times about seven
eight weeks ago you can find it john
Marburger and he said that is not a
scientific issue that is a quote sacred
issue
what's a sacred issue sacred issue i
guess he meant religious issue and i
think that's why there is trouble now
over stem cells scientists are saying
these are good President Bush is saying
that's life you know
well his site is his bioethicists are
saying we can't tell him it's life as
scientists the scientists have never
declared it to be life the Constitution
doesn't the statutes don't maybe we
should have a great debate in the United
States of America and bring everybody in
and say look forget about your religion
here's a proposition for you should we
say that life begins at conception
nobody wants to deal with this and I can
understand why I'm particularly
sensitive myself because I'm a Catholic
and I I know what the implications are
but maybe this should be a dialogue and
we should talk about it but you can't go
from my religion teaches me it nobody
else or mostly people don't accept that
religious proposition to making a law he
would never do that
Lincoln in my opinion he would first
have to find a secular rationale for the
law but that's a nice points a position
I take in the book it'll probably draw
us some heat but I think it's a
reasonable one I hope you read the book
please read the book now you notice I
said please read the book I didn't say
please buy the book if you're really
stingy wait till it gets to the
librarian but but read it eventually you
know no I I really because I worked very
hard on it it represents thoughts I've
had for a long time I I thought about it
for a long time I think it's all
responsible you may say it's wrong but I
think it can be very useful I hope
you'll read it and I hope now you'll
forgive me the length of this
presentation which is longer than I
wanted it to be and you'll pleasure me
with your questions I
you're very very much
okay who's going to start us
the who would you choose
hoo-wee just uses a candidate for vice
president I you know it's that's not a
question that's easy for an outsider to
answer because one of the prime
ingredients of a good vice president is
a person that the president feels very
comfortable with now comfortable is is
is something that I can't define because
I don't know whom John Kerry would be
comfortable with and and it doesn't
follow that a person who we you and I
agree is looks to us like a good
political bet he can get you this state
and that state and the polls say he's
very popular and he gives a good speech
like John Edwards for example it doesn't
follow that the president would be more
comfortable with him than then somebody
else who doesn't have those ingredients
why because it's a matter of confidence
you have to work with the person you
have to be able to take advice from that
person you have to respect that person's
experience John Kerry's been around for
thirty five years or whatever it is you
know he's been in that Senate for so
long and John Edwards for example has
only been there for one skimpy term and
and and you know it's this a question I
think President Bush had difficulty with
Dan Quayle the first president Bush not
it was a nice person I know Dan Quayle
have debated him a number of times he's
he's very Britta know he's he's not a
he's not a he's a very smart guy but he
didn't have the gravitas that President
Bush wanted and so they didn't use him
and and I think that has to be
considered I note he's spending time
with Gephardt
now that I can see him being comfortable
with get bought why get bought safe
kept us extremely well educated from his
years in the Congress he's well
respected by both sides he's not deemed
highly charismatic but you don't want a
vice president's highly charismatic you
know my mother had this wonderful
expression roughly translated
her rough Italian it was don't ever say
that to to her her daughter Marie my
sister don't ever think somebody will
tell you to wash your face so that you
look prettier than they do you know now
that that only the old ethnic spoke that
way you'd hope from bitter experience
and an abiding sense of reality but you
know they you don't necessarily want a
dashing vice president who every time
you get on a platform makes you look bad
by speaking better than you do so it's a
lot of things he has a lot of really
good possibilities I think there's a
larger possibility here to I'm very
eager to see him come up with a vice
president personally because I think
Kerry plus vice president against Bush
and Cheney is better than Kerry against
Cheney why because I think Cheney is
eventually going to be a drag on that
campaign because I think he has so many
negatives and and they're piling up and
Halliburton is not going to go away and
so I think would be good to be able to
run Kerry and roop against bush and
cheney against bush and cheney against
cheney and bush oh I'm sorry
Bush and Cheney you know the so I'd like
to see him get somebody and also what's
developing is there are several people
who you could announce as potential
parts of the camp the the group that
would be running and thus the
administration of John Kerry who would
be I think highly appealing I think Joe
Biden would be appealing to people on
the on the question you know Secretary
of State I think Wesley o'clock when
you're talking about military and you
say Wesley o'clock people say well what
the heck maybe you know he wasn't a
dazzling candidate it wasn't used to it
but he's certainly solid as a military
person and and you can start naming
names like that and of course you have
get pod and you have Edwards and you
have Richardson and all these people
would make good solid choices so at one
point I think we can expect to see that
a kind of showing off of the
tential administration people now you
asked me vice president I I don't know I
mean I really don't because I don't know
what Kerry feels here about these these
people and that may be the most
important thing of all can I live with
this person it's one thing to get
somebody to win the campaign yes you
have to win but you have to govern and
that's more important and you have to
have somebody who's going to help you be
a president who has the ability to do
that and you have to have a comfortable
a comfort level with them that will
allow him to express that ability yes
sir yes they're close to home what we
have here in Albany today and which of
course you have all that experience how
would we go about reforming this
horrible situation where you have a
legislature there that simply doesn't
work that if you read The Times today
you're talking about a governor who just
took off about well the whole place
going on vacation not even having a
budget how do we go about getting rid of
these people who can keep getting
elected all the time without doing a
damn thing for us well I can tell well
well I'm surprised I've no I'm not
surprised there is just a smattering of
applause because I think nobody knows
what's happening in Albany I really do
know I
Albany's another world for especially
people from New York City and and I
didn't realize it until I went up there
and and spent 12 years I my first job
was in Albany as a law clerk and the
court of appeals as a young pitcher but
the in Albany I said that nobody would
even know I was talking about but let me
tell you what I have been saying about
this since 1977 I went into public life
in 1975 and I said in 1977 you must
repair the system in Albany people in
Albany get reelected 98 99 percent of
the time
why of course they have a staff they
send newsletters to their assembly
district or their Senate districts
saying all the good things about them
nobody competes with them nobody wants
to spend a lot of time money to win an
assembly seat you know what is what is
Congress you want me to spend a million
dollars to be an assembly person so so
they don't spend a lot of money and so
this keeps them assured of incumbency
and once they're assured of incumbency
why should they change any of the rules
and so they don't I said this is only
going to get worse and it got worse in
my 12 years and those late budgets that
I got punished for in 1994 or later now
than ever and the system is more
dysfunctional now than it was in 1977
and I said the same thing every year and
I call the New York Times and ask them
about you must have a constitutional
convention you must gather up a
constitutional convention and sit back
and say listen we're going to start from
scratch we're going to take the
constitution of the state and we're
going to change it and we're going to
change it so that you can be guaranteed
99 percent turnover we're going to give
people on the outside a better
opportunity to know what you're doing up
there and to challenge you however we
have to do that we have to affect the
campaign finance reform that brings the
system closer to New York City's
campaign finance which is a much fairer
much more intelligent system in the
state uses you have to do a lot of
things now every time I said that say
here's the way it works constitutionally
and and the very complexity of it is
operates against it and it's one of the
reasons it hasn't happened every 20
years the constitutional convention
proposition appears on your ballot so it
was on the ballot in 77 it was on the
ballot again in 1997 in 1997 myself and
Jerry Benjamin who is a Republican from
upstate who's written books who's very
smart who teaches in New Paltz and he
very Republican very much different from
for my own politics but we're good
friends we both worked hard but we had
no money and a legislature worked
against us and the unions worked against
us because they were working with the
legislature and they
defeated the proposition in 77 and they
defeated the proposition in 97
now finally last week Quinnipiac took a
poll and Quinnipiac said to the people
of New York and everywhere do you think
we should have a constitutional
convention and the vote was 54 31 yes
let's have a constitutional convention
and what I'm hoping now and I've spoken
to some people is it let's get serious
if nothing else let's make it such a
real threat to this legislature that
they will do something if they don't
let's have a constitutional convention
and change the whole darn system and
that's that's the only answer nothing is
going to happen look it hasn't happened
since 1977 what makes you think it's
going to happen now unless you do
something dramatic and that's
Constitutional Convention yes sir you
used the word dialog which is word what
I studied with Hannah Arendt and she
used to say democracy is dialogue and I
feel for the first time in my life that
there is less dialogue in America on
every level there whether it's the press
whether it's Congress certainly what you
talked about the 28 second
you know ads in the campaign there's no
dialogue and even when the presidential
candidates go to speak there there's
such pacts you know they're using the
same language because they're afraid to
say anything that will not get them
elected rather than say I hope the
things that we are in their hearts I
just you know I so I'm just wondering is
there a way to go back and find dialog
in this country and isn't it necessary
to have a democracy well there are a
couple of things you can do and we can
we can do something with this film and
then let me come back to that but there
are a couple of things you could do I
talked about the inability to change the
situation in Albany because of the
structure of the law and the
constitution of the state etcetera the
same thing happens in Washington we now
have a campaign finance system that is
just out of control you can't correct it
fine fine gold and and McCain put
together a bill and everybody was
hopeful that would do something both the
Democrats and the Republicans found ways
around it and so now there's all kinds
of soft money you've got nothing done
well is there any answer well it's hard
to do because Buckley against Valeo
which is a Supreme Court precedent says
that a rich person who has great
individual wealth you can't stop them
from spending their own wealth and
therefore if you do construct the system
all you need is a rich person who has
his or her own wealth which in this
country we have now more billionaires
more well we're just short of our first
trillionaire I guess I guess the Gates
missed it by a little bit but no no I
don't think he got to a trillion but we
have more and more billionaires and more
and more millionaires millionaires a
commonplace now you know still only 2%
over 200,000 but a whole lot of
billionaires me and you put a few of
those together and they own the system
so what can you do well you can do this
we do have a lot of money in the federal
system that comes from taxpayers
you know the taxpayers put money and
they give it to the presidential
candidates you could if the legend if
the Congress wanted to they could at
least do this look we're going to give
you the money but we're going to be
demand and we're going to demand that it
gets spent in a way that produces a
better dialogue and so we're going to
give you the money but you can't have
any 28 second commercials what they're
too short you can have a five-minute
commercial because in five minutes if
you don't say anything you're really
gonna look pretty ridiculous 28 seconds
you can get away with it show if you
picture but if it would be about the
boats over so so that's one thing you
have to have 15 debates you have to have
a debate every week and it has to be a
certain kind of debate you say here here
are the debates now and debates are
better than the non debates but here are
the debates now if you have four
candidates or three candidate or even
two candidates the rates are give you a
minute to answer this question and I'll
give you 30 seconds to answer okay you
13 debates you ask the terrorism
question 13 times you get the same
one-minute in the same 30 seconds and it
never gets any deeper and so we should
structure it so that look here's the
kind of Inquisition we're going to have
we're gonna have the candidates we're
going to have good inquisitors or dumb
smart people who will question you and
you can bring Cheney and you can bring
your assistant you can bring your books
if you want in the beginning of the
campaign but we're gonna ask you every
big question terrorism the intelligence
what did you do what didn't you do and
we're gonna let you answer those
questions and put them all on record
right in the beginning of the campaign
we're gonna keep now we're not gonna
print it all but we're gonna keep it on
record and every reporter will know you
can spend a whole day on the account I
did this with the New York Times in 1994
just to try it I said let me come in you
can have all the time you want to ask me
any question on the economy I will
answer it I'll bring people with me if I
need them to help me that's the way you
govern you don't do it by yourself a
debate shouldn't be a test of glibness
god forbid what you get is a glib
president you know should we drop the
bomb well let me tell you buddy for to
be of course for you you should ask
people you should study you should think
so so there are ways by conditioning the
use of campaign finance you can force
them to have a more intelligent campaign
and that's something that the Congress
will have to do but if the people figure
that idea out they can put the pressure
on the Congress to get it done now let
me talk to you again about this film
it's true that I was retained as a
lawyer it's true that tomorrow we have
an appeal which by some strange accident
they have said I can't appear in Los
Angeles personally notwithstanding I was
negotiating with them for three days to
go from an r-rating to a pg-13 for a lot
of complicated reasons because the
audience is larger with a pg-13 than an
R although most people don't really know
what an R is and most people don't
really know what a pg-13 is the the net
effect is that our costs of ten to
twenty percent of the the audience so
anyway I was negotiating trying to get
done our artist Michael Moore and the
producers didn't want to give up what
they wanted us to give up because they
thought too much of the truth went some
graphic images that they wanted to leave
in the leave in the film and so I have
written my argument which got published
today in San Diego it's only five pages
and it'll be delivered for me at the
Appeal tomorrow we don't know how we're
going to do they tell us well it's not
hopeful you probably get stuck with an R
and if that's the case that's the case
but he is the opportunity this film
gives us and here's why I took it it's
not because I'm a Democrat and this is
good for the Democrats which it probably
is but but this can be good for the
process why I saw the film before I
agreed to represent the producer
I saw it three times I saw it myself
I saw it with Matilda I saw it with
Matilda and my daughter Maria and her
husband Ken and her their kids three
kids and we watched it and I watched the
whole thing and and so I'm absolutely
convinced that the other side will be
upset and will say well the insinuation
there is not fair and this is not fair
fine that's wonderful step forward and
let's conduct the debate and the
dialogue using that documentary and why
don't you do a documentary just go out
and do a documentary you can do it we
talked about not wait but the film talks
about prince Bandar you know the prime
minister of Saudi Arabia two days after
9/11 sitting with the President of the
United States for dinner
privately for three hours great what did
you talk about the people who were
involved the terrorists with Saudi
Arabians did you talk about that the MA
dresses are being fed with Saudi Arabian
money
the madra PSA's are teaching young
Muslims to kill the infidels
we are the infidels and everybody knows
that maybe billion
of dollars have gone into those schools
did you talk about that you say we imply
terrible things we said nothing we said
you sat down and had dinner 2 days after
9/11 where you got three hours to have
dinner with the Prime Minister quietly
in that madness how you were able to
find three hours I don't know but you
did and we want the American people to
know it and because the American people
are going to say to you mr. president
please explain that so step forward and
explain it if you can explain it
score one for you and oh and so on and
so forth the film gives us an
opportunity to have a much better
campaign than you could have without it
because it is not a speech it is not an
unchallenged address given to a captive
audience all Republicans here all
Democrats there I give a speech which
you know says only my side of the case
they all cheer that's on the television
that night for five seconds six seconds
seven seconds and then maybe you have
two or three debates and you know what
the debates are going to be the
president will keep them down to the
most the minimum length and since the
answer will only be a minute and a half
how much trouble can you get in I mean
as a matter of fact if you talk very
slowly you can get away without saying
anything and so that that's what I want
you to keep your eye on with this film
just don't let them say well it's a lot
of baloney Michael Moore lied when he
was in grammar school you know I don't
like the way he dresses he's too happy
you know I mean forget all of that
that is called on homing them that is to
distract you from the film what you
should say and I'm not saying you should
all believe every and every implication
in the film just use it to give us a
better debate than we're having now
because you're right
the debate now is awful it's awful and
and it just does not get to the heart of
the matter and everybody knows it hear
your opinion about Congress and why
there
stepping up more at this time when we
have a weak president and what they can
do and they didn't do to get us into
this situation we're in and how they can
help to get Congress personally first of
all Congress has the right to declare
war and to insist on it
Congress has the right to say mr.
president don't do a thing on this don't
pull a trigger on this until you come to
us and we take a look at it and declare
war Congress hasn't done that I guess
since the Second World War
why because they don't want to they
passed the War Powers Act that every
president has ignored every president
said now it's unconstitutional and
nobody ever went to court why they don't
want to Congress doesn't want to face
the responsibility of Congress should
have it's as simple as that
and you can get into trouble that way
and we got into trouble the Democrats
got into trouble how well you know this
some of them voted for the resolution so
let's face it look at the Constitution
says who declares war the Congress does
did they declare war here did they
declare in Vietnam where did they
declare it when's the last time so
Congress is taking a pass now as to
asserting power in the Congress I hope
that all because the Republicans are in
charge of both the houses and they're
the ones with the power the most the
Democrats can do is every once in a
while get lucky with a clever device and
slow you down or force you you know to
just stymie the situation because you
can't get enough votes to override their
stymie action but that's all negative
the sadness of Nancy Pelosi's position
and and the position in the Senate with
Tom Daschle is that these are
wonderfully bright people with good
ideas who want to do good things but
they have no efficacy to speak of of
course the system allows the majority to
block everything the minority can't
block everything but the majority can
and that's what's happening and so what
do you do about that well if you get a
president that that will help a little
bit
maybe even a lot because the president
has a lot of power to most of all he has
the bully pulpit and the bully pulpit is
the greatest power you can have and
that's how that's how Lincoln won
everything that he wanted it was from
the podium by standing up and debating
Douglass in the first place over and
over on slavery and coming from oblivion
as a politician in a world where there
was no television then you had to read
the debates and word-of-mouth had to
travel around the country to the extent
that it could he achieved enough popular
by coming to New York to Cooper Union
and giving a great address in Cooper
Union where you know he was he had never
been here was an alien alien world to
him and he got up to that podium and
delivered a masterpiece of analysis and
poetry and history was marvelous and
that's the way he won through the power
of that bully pulpit so if Kerry would
have win even if you don't win one house
would be nice if you could win one house
would be glorious if he could win two
well some people would say that's too
much if you had the president and both
houses then you got a bush situation
it's a Republican president and both
houses and that means Supreme Court god
forbid what these people will do to the
Supreme Court if you give him four more
years because there's gonna be a lot of
empty seats over the next four years and
if you have and this is in the book to
Lincoln and President Bush and President
Roosevelt and most presidents have this
tendency in common they want people that
they are politically compatible with not
just the best judge because the best use
theoretically in picking a justice for
the Supreme Court you shouldn't know
anything about their politics I'm not
going to ask you about theoretically I'm
not going to ask you about Roe against
Wade I'm not going to ask you to tell me
that you'll vote this way or that way
because every
has to be decided a new row against Wade
was decided in 1973 it says that
viability is at 24 weeks what does that
mean it means that at 24 weeks the fetus
can live outside the womb and that was
critical because at that point they said
the woman's right to abort becomes much
much much less only to save her own life
or health
can she abort at that stage that's a big
deal if you were to try Roe against Wade
now what do you think science would say
about the period of viability
I suspect suspect I'm not a scientist
but just from what I read I suspect it
wouldn't be 24 weeks to be a lot less
that they would conclude that because of
various changes in treatment etc etc
it's possible for the fetus to survive
outside the womb in an era at an
earliest stage in which case that
reduces the number of abortions that are
possible so so you have all all of this
going on a lot more counties I can say a
lot more but I'd better not yeah yes you
think you would like to see governor of
New York after Pataki is out there
anyone I'd like to see as governor of
New York yes I can think of two people
in this order me and my son actually
actually let me make that my son and I
first of all I want to say I Meyer your
courage because you stand up and you
tell us as it is Fahrenheit 9/11 being
such a controversial subject and I wish
the Democratic Party and their
representatives would exhibit the same
courage I really you say you know Kerry
I don't know Kerry he voted for it
before he voted against it and for 35
years his record I don't know the man
now as far as them I am a Democrat but
I'm getting very disappointed for
instance Daschle our speaker voted with
the Republicans for the late term
abortion and that to me was a tremendous
disappointment and a weakness I would
like to hear you your opinion on that
well I think that excuse me that's going
to be decided by the Supreme Court the
argument on the late term abortion is
really a Roe against Wade argument if in
fact the ROE against Wade decision was
and this the constitutional law at this
moment is Roe against Wade it's not a
statute it's ro against Wade that
decision if the constitutional law of
Roe against Wade is as I believe it is
that in that last trimester it doesn't
talk about the method of abortion it
talks about whether you can you can't
have an abortion you can not have an
abortion unless the woman shows that it
is a serious matter of health or even
her life life more obvious than help and
so to say now even if it's going to
endanger you you can't do it that way
would be a contradiction of Roe against
Wade and so you're facing an
unconstitutional bill and that's what
the courts have said so far they've said
look whatever you think about this
process Roe against Wade says that you
know that's the law this is a land of
law if you want to change it you've to
one of two things you have to get lucky
those of you who want to change and get
a judge or judges who will see the case
differently and who next time they get
Roe against Wade will alter it in a way
that bans these abortions so one way to
change the law is by getting judges to
do it the other way is a constitutional
amendment okay now the cut for the
absolutists
on the issue of abortion for the
fundamentalists on the issue of abortion
who deride all those who don't agree
with them and say you know you're wrong
for not standing up for the absolute law
I don't know anybody who has stood up
for the absolute law the absolute law
fundamentally is know abortions except
to save the life of the mother why don't
you ask for a constitutional amendment
to do that if you really believe in that
if all you Republicans will put it into
your campaign every year at the every
presidential year it's in there in the
campaign it's up there and this is our
platform we believe life begins at
conception then you should ask for a
constitutional amendment because the
court hasn't done it for you why don't
you step forward and say to the United
States of America okay your women even
if you have to die you can't have an
abortion why don't you say that of
course they'll reject it that's why well
then say to me rather than I'm an
absolutist and anything less is
hypocrisy say I'm not really an
absolutist what I'm really saying is
there are too many abortions and we have
to find a way to limit the number
because the absolute position is life
begins at conception
that's the Roman Catholic teaching and
the answer to that has to be a
constitutional amendment that says no
abortion at any stage not a minute after
conception nobody's ever asked for that
not Regan not Bush one not Bush two no
Republicans nobody campaigns on it
nobody have you ever heard anybody
campaigner and nobody will nobody will
so what else can I say say what I think
you should have been on the Supreme
Court we wouldn't need to worry so much
now
let me let me look let me tell you about
the screen fort and let me get all the
way back to the point about Lincoln and
the difference between the Constitution
and the Declaration of Independence and
the difference between the Constitution
and what the country really needs the
Constitution gives us freedom and
liberty thank God we have that but we
need much more we need a society that
understands interconnectedness and
interdependence a society that knows we
should have health care for everybody
who needs it everybody who needs it you
should a society that understands that
you should have you shouldn't spend two
trillion dollars in a trillion dollars
on me and my clients when when you've
got people who are truly suffering in
this society you know to say that
Medicaid takes care of the elderly ill
is a joke it's a joke
Medicaid of Medicare Medicare doesn't do
what the elderly need you you know what
the problem is with drugs and that
hasn't been solved prescription drugs we
have so many needs only one out of four
workers in this country is high skilled
only one out of four that means only one
out of four have gotten four years
beyond high school we some years ago
gave two hundred thousand visas for
people to be computer engineers and so
they started here from overseas they
came here and got $80,000 our average
wage was thirty-eight thousand dollars
and we were giving them eighty thousand
because we didn't educate our own people
to do that work how does that make any
sense now none of that can you solve by
sitting in a robe and look I've said
over and over personally Supreme Court
Wow
what a job no fundraising
nothing dental care until you're a
hundred you know you don't even have to
wear pants you can come to work and
sneakers and shorts nobody would know
you're the robot you know it's it's
wonderful but but you couldn't do what
I'm doing at this moment you couldn't do
what I'm doing with them now maybe
nobody listens what I get maybe
everybody disagrees you went there and
you lost everybody oh maybe so but at
least I tried at least I made my case at
least I used the Lincoln at least I
pleaded with people to go see the film
at least I said just think about it a
little bit more wouldn't it be better if
instead of putting that money there we
we took that trillion dollars back put
some into education some into healthcare
some into tax cuts for the local
governments where they have such
problems wouldn't that be better if I
just left a little idea in your head I
wouldn't be allowed to do that as a
Supreme Court justice I couldn't get up
here and make a political speech it's a
sin and a civic sin if you did it so so
you know the notion that well if you
were there you get three or four cases a
year maybe they're very very important
this way I can argue every day of my
life on things that are really very very
important to the American people yes yes
ma'am
I have to tell you that I do agree with
that decision that you made years ago I
agreed at the time that when you turned
it down for these reasons you need your
voice I said that against thank you for
you talk to Matilde what I know that
your advisors and your family didn't
agree with you but I did for this very
reason your voice is precious and it
would be silenced thank you very much
thank you and then the other thing I
wanted to ask you about was I'm
concerned with Kerry and his ability to
pull it off because I just am I mean you
know and I'm not like I wanted to know
had you considered because I agreed with
your and I don't I can only speculate
why you didn't run when everybody was
asking you to run him was it 92 whatever
I can only speculate and I thought he
couldn't win because he's too true to
his principles and the climate was very
different like the way you couldn't win
because of death penalty in the state
you know whatever you're not going to
change just to get elected
so I don't know what your reasons were
but I wanted to know had you considered
running this time and if not why not
and I think we need you now more than
ever because nobody spends no no no I
didn't very good very quickly I know I
didn't consider it this time but but I
want I do want to talk about carry and
and if you heard this story stop me but
my mother death death penalty and my
mother 1977 I'm running against Ed Koch
Son of Sam is running around you don't
remember that summer what a summer we're
running for mayor and she comes in she
says may you know under electric chair I
said no she's my gotcha one the electric
chair I said yes I know a woman who came
to the store and says how come your son
is so big is so strong he's so stupid in
us so weak whoa and she says you gotta
have the electric chair you gotta kill
him and they animals some of these
people of mine and I gave her all the
arguments why you know it's wrong you'd
be too bad so and she says that's all
then are you gonna lose I said so I'll
lose you want me to change my mind mind
I'm your baby you want me to change your
mind my mind just to win the election
and she says no you don't have to change
here's what you do you're telling me you
won the electric chair after you win get
it
No
Kerry Kerry John Kerry I believe very
sincerely has everything you need to win
and I believe he will win no no no just
see right now it is as I pointed out for
very good reasons because the focus is
where it should be on terrorism etc and
some people are thinking about the
economy but but not clearly yet and
they're not paying attention to carry so
much they're paying attention to
President Bush and so it's a bush
against Bush and Bush is losing and no I
mean no he's losing points in the
standings and under those circumstances
you know if you were Kerry why should
you step in front of him you have two
problems if you do that you may distract
from whatever the forces are that are
driving pushed down in the polls and you
might be you know blamed for stepping in
front of your commander-in-chief in the
middle of you know a very difficult time
and and and that's not good for the
country so he's got that against him but
before this is over as I said before
they the people are going to turn the
camera and say okay now John it's your
turn and that's when he has to make his
stand and show that he's different
and that's when he does have to take the
president on and say some different
things and there are two three things
you know I I did this on Jon Stewart's
show one night they said well what what
do you think Kerry can say and I said ah
he can say a lot if for example he would
have the opportunity and he looked at
the American people and said look you
don't really know me well let me tell
you about myself very very briefly I
love this country for the same reason
you do it's been very good to me and my
family and my case probably been better
to my family than it was to yours
and I loved it so much that when Vietnam
came I volunteered along with other
people to risk my life for my country
and I did and I got medals I'm not sure
I deserved them but I got them and I was
grateful but I did something more and so
did others something much much more
and volunteer to risk my life I
volunteered to kill for my country and I
did more than once and I came back with
such a detestation when it occurred to
me that maybe I did that in a war that
was not necessary and that was wrong and
I pledged to myself then that for the
rest of my life I would do everything I
possibly could to be sure that I did not
allow us to go to war unless it was
clear beyond a reasonable doubt that we
needed to that's why I'm so sad about
Iraq yes I voted for it I expected the
President to do more diplomacy but I and
he didn't that disappointed me but I
voted for it and so did other people we
were fooled we were fooled by poor
intelligence we'll fold I don't think
the president lied I think he was fooled
too and I'll tell you if I am president
I'll never never never allow that to
happen again but it was a mistake and on
as to where we are in Iraq it's good
that we got rid of Saddam I doubt we can
make these people a democracy in a hurry
I'll get our forces back as soon as
possible but not until I'm sure that
there will not be chaos there because
then we'll only have to go back but I
will tell you this you cannot win the
war against terrorism unless you do a
lot more than just catch and kill and
imprison terrorists which I'll promise
to do we have to do more with respect to
the mod races spell it out we have to do
more with respect to the economy as the
president himself admitted but didn't do
spell that out the two powell programs
and as to the economy I simply want to
say this to the American people don't be
fooled by financial pages of the best
newspapers and economists telling you
the economy is good it is good by all
the economic measures it's very good but
that's not the test
the test for the American people is is
it good for you
the economy is very very good for me and
my clients the economy is good for what
David Brooks called in The Times this
week the aristocracy of money he said
he's a conservative there are two
aristocracies up at the top the
aristocracy of ideas the people who want
evidence ideas intelligence and the
aristocracy for money those people who
manage organizations have produced
products for profit and he put President
Bush in the aristocracy of money and he
said the aristocracy of ideas is
offended that he doesn't read newspapers
yeah I am offended doesn't need to read
newspapers but if you don't read
newspapers you probably don't read books
either and if you don't read books you
know I don't know and you're not
watching my documentary I don't know
where you're getting your facts so so he
you know there is plenty he can say he
has the record he has Israel his record
on Israel is perfect his he's got a
hundred percent AIPAC record on Israel
he it's clear to everybody that one of
the things you have to do to deal with
terrorism is to make sure you make peace
in Israel I don't think we really tried
President Bush is very popular with the
Jewish community I'm surprised I'm
surprised how popular no no I think I
understand it he was popular because
were very clever in the beginning if you
go all the way back to his campaign he
made no moves toward Israel he was
diffident toward Israel he didn't want
to play any role and then he came over
the plan and the plan was if you get rid
of our Rifat and you get rid of the
terrorists then you come back to me and
I'll help you with my plan come back in
three years that was after this election
and everybody said that's great he's
saying all the
things that Sharona and the Israelis
wanted to hear but when he said three
years after the election I said wait a
minute
sure it's nice but say a year say
something else we let's get in the game
here
let's help Israel don't step back and
say get rid of verified and get rid of
terrorism how are they going to do it
without you how are they gonna how are
you going to put the pressure on them
without the United States of America so
he's got a perfect record on Israel he
can do plenty on the issue of Israel and
that's important way beyond the Jewish
community it's important because it's
being used as a provocation and an
excuse for terrorism so we have to help
Israel make peace and how do you do that
by putting pressure on Israel no god
forbid I'm not even an even-handed in
this guy I mean when people say you know
you should be even-handed well I don't
know exactly what you mean by that
we helped create Israel Israel is our
ally because they're the only democracy
like us they're the only value system
exactly like us in that part of the
world that really counts they've been
there for us as long as we've been there
for them and I think we have a special
obligation to them as a matter of fact
you can't have peace unless we serve as
guarantor of their security because once
they make a deal with them how do you
know they won't turn around at some
point Israel's enemies and say we didn't
really mean it you have to be there the
United States America as guarantor of
performance for Israel in that deal and
and I think Kerry will probably say
something like that at the right time so
I think there's plenty he can do he has
the skill he has the mind he has one
problem no no no no no no no no no the
problem is this he is subtle the problem
is he is nuanced the problem is he is
intelligent and that is his problem you
know this is a complicated thing to
operate on very complicated to operate
on it takes fine instruments and that's
what Kerry is using the other guy is
using a
the simplest tool known to mankind you
know and everybody understands it and he
speaks that way and he kind and
everybody says that's the world drop a
bomb on their head this is a tough guy
hit her last question after all is said
and done doesn't the war really come
down to one thing
oil I mean Bush is an oil man
his father was an oil man there's a
corporate oil conglomerate through his
left and to his right
I mean he's not looking to bring the
democracy to the Mideast he wants to
control the Mideast so we can control
the oil supply I you know maybe maybe in
the beginning that was somebody's
aspiration I think it certainly is the
history of this country and particularly
if you see the the Fahrenheit 9/11 you
will see a heavy emphasis on the Carlyle
corporation it has baffled me from the
beginning why that wasn't a whole series
in every newspaper in the United States
what is the Carlyle corporation how come
James Baker and George Bush after
they've finished went and did business
with all these people in the Carlyle
Corporation what are all these
relationships of billions of dollars
being made by Americans why are you so
caused cozy with it I mean there's
plenty of reason to want to know more
about that situation and maybe in the
beginning
the fact that there was oil there and
you we're very good at that as a country
let's face it we have gone all over the
world to where the resources were and
plucked and picked the fruit off the
trees and left them behind barren we've
done that
let's and other places we've developed
and we've done good things but we're
capable of that I don't see the evidence
now and whatever they thought of in the
beginning even if that was on their mind
we're going to grab hold of the oil that
they've lost the chance to get away with
it at this point it's not going to
happen the United Nations is not going
to let it happen the rest of the world's
not going to let it happen and and and
Halliburton is not going to get away
with anything and it's an ally that's
right as long as we can keep Cheney on
the ticket with bush
you know it's it's it's a nice it's a
nice thing to have floating out there in
the atmosphere but I I can't candidly
say I see oil as a motivation at this
point I mean whatever aspiration they
might have had in the beginning it just
didn't work out where they could wind up
with the oil
all right last question okay just bring
the subject back to the book when you
first addressed us you said what
motivated you inspired you to write the
book was the first anniversary of 9/11
right and frankly I was disappointed in
our politicians that they went to
Lincoln and I was wondering because I
think if Lincoln were alive today he
would have found the words himself so I
was wondering if in the book you
addressed what Lincoln might have said
on that day not not directly but yes I
think if you go to page 166 no no I
Lincoln speaks in the book he there's a
whole speech by Lincoln and it does deal
with 9/11 and it does deal with his
feelings on 9/11 and let me just on the
subject of speaking let's be very candid
about this one of the one of the people
in the audience made a very intelligent
point and that is it's not always easy
to say the truth as you see it I
remember the day after 9/11 I guess was
the day after 9/11 Diane Sawyer I'm not
sure now was such a terrible mess for
all of us and so confusing and we had we
had had an office there in 1993 the
first time it blew up we had an office
on the 57th floor because I was governor
at that time and you know it you go back
to all those recollections and Diane
Sawyer asked me about what you know
aren't there a lot of questions that
come out of this governor you were there
what and you spoke to the Secret Service
and the CIA and the Secret Service had
an office in the building and the CIA
and all these people and don't you have
questions I said sure do you know why we
didn't do more
happened to the intelligence system etc
etc and I said there were other
questions and and and maybe one of the
biggest ones is why what would possess
these people what is that that drives
them to hate us so much that they would
surrender their own life to take ours
what is that is that mad Zella tree I
mean and and if so you know what fuels
that hate and I said look we're
obviously going to find out who did it
and we will go after them with a
vengeance and we will tear them to bits
one way or another we'll bring our armed
forces and then that's true but I hope
that in the process we don't forget that
we need to find the source of this
what's creating this crime what's
creating this hate and Diane said
something like well I think that's very
intelligent and I got killed I got phone
calls notes you mushy headed lower the
root causes how dare you suggest that
we're wrong I didn't suggest we're wrong
I said we have to end incidentally it's
still true that's what the moderates are
all about you look for an explanation
you find it you find it in the schools
the schools are teaching children to
hate that's one reason you find it in
the streets of a Middle East that used
to be the most powerful place in the
world for a considerable period of time
that lived through the Crusades in which
we were barbarous the infidels and
Christians ate Muslim babies alive in
some of the Crusades you know you look
for those things you said well what do
we do about that how do we have you've
got to do that but when you say it there
are a lot of people out there and say I
seasoned that if you just say well I
promise you we will get them we will
chase them we will find we will fry them
we will hang them we won't give them a
trial we'll have the Patriot Act and
then you get a considerable number the
people say that's exactly what I want
and and that's a big problem subtlety is
a problem and sometimes telling the
whole truth is about
there's only a small example death Bella
is only a small example but I lived to
20 or 30 years of poles at 80 20 75 25
you kept saying look you're killing
innocent people and it's not doing any
good and you're not making things better
and now you have DNA and it's obvious
that you have been killing innocent
people all along and it doesn't do any
good and and still there's a reluctance
for people to face that why because
you're taking vengeance away from them
and to some people that that's all they
have they're so frustrated god forbid
you lose somebody somebody gets killed
somebody buy it buy some butchers some
madman and and for some people that's
all they have is that you know that
feeling of at least I got even and
that's a very powerful thing and that's
what the country felt after 9/11 and
still does feel to a large extent and
it's perfectly human but here they asked
me the question they asked mike dukakis
about the death penalty said what would
happen if something has somebody touched
one of your children or or Matilde or
something I said I would kill them I'm
sure I would kill them I'd go crazy I
probably grab them and strangle them but
you can't make laws that accommodate
your worst moment as a human being you
have to be able to understand that's a
wrong reaction no matter how human it is
and the human reaction to 9/11 human
reaction to the death penalty is not us
at our best and what you need is us at
our best thank you very very much god
bless
Thank You Governor Cuomo for sharing
your words of wisdom and I also want to
thank Ivano Cuomo for being one of the
best friends the 92nd Street Y has ever
had thank you all for coming please join
us for a book selling and signing